A single page application
is a self-contained page
that has its own user interface and
logic.
It can talk to the server to send and
receive data,
then store that data locally.
You can immediately interact with
the data by modifying, deleting or
creating new content.
It's fast and there are no page reloads.
You've already played
around with TodoMVC, but
I want to quickly focus on this MVC.
What is it?
MVC stands for Model, View, Controller
and its a common design pattern for
organizing software of any
kind including web apps.
Many frameworks provide a means for
creating and managing models, views and
controllers.
Model refers to a data model.
It's everything from the user
information to any data that you
might want to see.
View is what users see and
interact with.
For a web site, the view is
essentially any HTML, CSS and
JavaScript that controls how
a page looks and behaves.
Last is the controller,
this is the brain of your application.
It sits between the model and
the view and
is in charge of passing
data between them.
It contains all the templating logic,
routing logic and
anything else that
makes your app unique.
If you want a refresher on MVC, I highly
recommend checking out our course,
JavaScript Design Patterns or
the link in the instructor notes.
Okay, now back to TodoMVC.
When I add this item as a new task,
I'm interacting with the apps of U, but
the controller is watching this and
is saving what I enter to the model.
We've looked at single page applications
in action and looked at a common way to
architect them, but
how do frameworks fit into this?